fell off
a site that's becoming all too common in
the occupied West Bank hundreds of
mourners gather for the funerals of two
Palestinians one of them was shot in the
chest several times during
confrontations with Israeli forces on
Monday after they entered the village of
kofardan and demolished two homes
the houses belonged to the families of
two Palestinian men who were killed in
September while carrying out an attacker
to checkpoint an Israeli soldier was
killed
the Palestinian Health Ministry says
several Palestinians were injured in the
latest Crossfire the Israeli military
says its troops came under heavy fire
and fought back
they made two families homeless the
eventual it's Collective punishment if
they could they would demolish the
entire area
of demolishing the houses of
Palestinians accused of killing Israelis
this could also include the homes of
their families or relatives the United
Nations reports that Israel has forced
more than a thousand Palestinians out of
their homes in the occupied West Bank
and that was just last year but since
2009 it's demolished more than 9 000
homes and buildings including those
provided by humanitarian assistance
Israel says it does this to deter
Palestinians from launching attacks the
human rights organization says it
amounts the collective punishment and
it's the families and relatives who end
up being targeted so we might see the
ICC for example looking into cases of
forcible transfer or the destruction of
properties
as work brings and crimes against
humanity
but of course with the culture of
infinity that we've witnessed with
regards to Israel and this entrenched
failure of the International Community
to hold Israel to an account has allowed
Israel and uh to continue with these
crimes and these violations
elsewhere in the occupied West Bank
Israeli forces made several arrests with
a focus on Bethlehem Nablus and Hebron
Palestinian media say the detainees were
taken to jail on charges of resisting
the occupation
there are now concerns with Israel's new
Ultra right-wing government that more
Palestinians might be at risk of death
or even displacement
Al Jazeera Negev